welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz and today
I'm in the very cool and funky Weiser
offices and I'm joined by April Turner
who is a growth manager and working for
the wiser
elite team and we're in the dark room we
are in a dark room today we've got some
lights and a bit more light and it's a
soundproof isn't it awesome yeah so for
those that haven't checked out the
Weiser offices there they're pretty cool
though yeah once so rewards for it
nice really cool here but as I was just
saying where I always always like to
start April is so it's a bit of a funny
one actually I I think I was just born
in Turks my mum had Roma cream and
company he was born into she had OMA
cream company she was like Top Billing
hunters for like four years in a row not
good noise yeah okay and then I
obviously used to come home from school
and not know day was the same for her so
it was like one day was like yeah I've
been a client yeah it's not the same
every day mmm so I was like fine and
then you know it got brother he's five
years older than me he steps into
recruitment now he's built a really
successful tech recruitment company so I
think it was always just meant to happen
I would this is the first time that ever
happened okay cool so a few things
within that then so just quickly to
frame aren't so born into recruitment
yes then works for one business for how
many years I work for status for three
not just over three years yeah yeah and
then you went into tech sales I did and
then you're now here at wiser yeah right
okay cool so I'm excited to to go
through that journey with you but
firstly I have to say like go up growing
up then what the hell was your
perception of recruitments you touched
on it a bit there like my mom one day
would be absolutely buzzing I love this
job and gun taking on big bitter lunches
and I don't
absolutely.i loving it right and then
that's that's really interesting you
also notice the she was have some really
bad days and yeah so I guess like what
was your perception growing up or
recruitment in and how did that evolve
by the time you got into it I think yeah
that's like everyone's perception right
who's that up and down all the time like
no one day was the same but like it's
from an early age you just get this view
on it that whatever it would like pay
your way through life and you're quite
quickly just pick up on everything right
so even from like a young age like yeah
I would say you're seven from the minute
I really understood like any business
language I pulley knew a lot more than
someone in my ear just really my mom
would speak or my brother would speak
alright so then and then would the day
at to be encouraged to get into the
industry my mom always said that I'd be
good at it just because I like love
people right but she said that maybe you
know the up and down part I won't enjoy
as much but yeah definitely my mom
pushed it not in a bad way but more all
right and then a quick one then like how
did they sell it to you I'll be
interested my mom how does she sell it I
don't think she had to sell it to me I
think it was more her like seeing I
loved what she was doing yeah you should
try it so I was like when I left school
at 17 it was like that age it's like do
I just get a job and like customer
service or being a state agent and I was
said to my mom I'm going to interview at
Fox and she was like I just just don't
do that just like get get into London
you want new weekends yeah exactly
well recruited you want your evening yes
she just said like getting so how did
she not get you should not get you into
some companies and like they just do
that all yourself I know I did that
myself that's how I found syrtis I mean
is there JB the yeah I see at the time I
hated my job when I came in okay cool
and then I guess like when when that
happens I guess through that process you
must have been like yeah I know
recruitment light my family do it like
how did you then because that must be
interesting that you've got two people
that are close to you there are in there
what did you sort of look out for when
joining the company always you just open
so just getting involved getting
straight into it these lots of things
it's actually funny you say that smooth
when I had my three interviews in London
I was a
in one was it networks international
without oil and gas recruitment I
comment the other one it was at high
street I think and then they were syrtis
and without any prompt I just knew that
what what company be right for me
obviously like summer just like boiler
room environment lads that not one
female on the sales floor
just like literally all four four
gravitated to you toward service that I
think it was just you know like there
they push that whole like young people
dreaming big like get in and we'll give
you the opportunity and like James
Thomas it a guy who was there I still
Tuesday would say he's the best I've
ever met really yeah he just liked the
way he sold it and like the impact that
he had in a room you just I want to work
for this guy nothing about that then
like Warsaw because it's really
interesting to say that so we'll we'll
get onto this because obviously part of
your new Ron now is employed branding
and I have my own view on that from my
own experience and when we were working
with agencies and a big obviously
challenges get attracting talent right
yeah and for me I just think a lot of
people missed the part when they go to
promote the the office environment and
only promote that and don't elevate
people like that that person that you
met in the room do you I mean I think
there's a really big thing that people
were missing this you know I mean we'll
get into that but I guess talk a bit
about like what what did that presence
feel like and how did he said that why
was it so impressive and why did it sort
of get you bought in even though you're
brought in but like you were like 100%
I'm working for them and no one else
talked about if we're looking at
timewise he's 2030 mites when I was six
years on and people look at other
elements like a ping-pong table and a
beer fridge you know like quirky offices
which is all great but at the time
you're so like organic and like fresh to
the industry that the thing that you're
being solely sold on is the person in
front of you hmm
so it's like then you're going can I get
is this guy gonna get me earning 60 70
grand my first year yes or no because
that's what recruitment was solely based
on now it's like is this person is
coming gonna get me through mental
health like diversity like having fun
and making friends but then it was like
right is this person gonna make me like
a millionaire yeah that's how a Rolex or
[Laughter]
okay
no I love that it's really interesting
so um okay so then I'll see you is
therefore a really sort of since that's
cool I think the fact the like that was
your first job and you had already sort
of time there how are you first four
months they were hard so I think at one
point for the first five months I cried
at least twice a week really really hard
about just like you know you know
booking in a candidate and then not
showing up for for like a meeting with
you
you know and the mindset then it was
like we wouldn't go out and meet
candidates you'd get them in the office
right so it's like get in the office and
then you'd be waiting we waiting at 6:30
they wouldn't show up yeah you know that
kind of thing you'd be like why what
have I done wrong and then you like
wouldn't be closing the deals and you'd
be solely relying on your consult to
close the deal when it would just be
that impact remember it was like months
it nine or ten and it clicked and I did
like 47k in my first like billing month
is it as every certain researcher was
like this is why you just have to keep
going let's definitely unpack that
because a lot of people listen to this
who difference between have been doing
recruitment for a while where early on
in these things so a few a few things
around that then April is so firstly
just give me a bit of context so did you
just go straight and focus on candidates
like what was you recruiting for yet so
I worked for what was called at digital
which is a combination of like events
publishing business information okay and
you went straight in sourcing candidate
started learning across that way yeah
and then would you support and someone
else that would you working on jobs that
other concerns and how big was the
agency actually really interesting and
okay so was cracking on canvas etc when
did you then start doing BD I would say
well BD was always like ingrained from
the get-go so we would do cold calling
from 10:00 to 11:00 every morning what
when you first I yeah oh yeah okay cool
so and so you said you had that huge
month yeah but I leading up to that like
what went on you said he was crying
twice we like did you build much need
not not me that much I think like the
most I'd pull you down at that point
seven and a half K so just over
threshold so really enough to realize in
the per month
no not consistent I joined in like
February so February maybe like October
November time I done combined 25k really
which wasn't that good yeah I build 24k
my first year oh I guess interesting
understand that is like you mentioned
there they clicked so I guess leading up
to that point firstly like so you said a
bit about people letting you down in
these things like was it anything else
in there that like was just causing this
emotion to be light was you doubting
yourself and would you like just not
understanding why you why wasn't working
with you've ever been environment where
you have to do something right so one
thing I always say is they don't teach
you enough at school is like really how
to you know adapt to working environment
you head down or be consistent or don't
get distracted so you've gone from
running around in a playground like
selling cookies from Sainsbury's and not
really having any responsibility to
actually going into a working
environment where you've got a 50 year
old guy telling you to get on the phone
yes it was like I don't even know what
I'm good at I don't know what me to get
do this job and I'm not cold calling and
I'm trying to get through that party's
gatekeepers and it's up what am i doing
I'm seeing these people that success but
I'm not getting there why am I not and I
think the biggest problem that people
have is that they want it now
yeah they think they can get in just get
on the phone and make money straightaway
and that's quite honest you're not the
reality sorry for those that think is I
think that's really well put so I guess
what what made you get through that then
like so I guess that that month must
have been a huge moment but like what
what what cuz a lot of people would have
quit like if they like if they're going
home if their mum wasn't a recruit right
they're going home and I was coming home
and she's crying she's like April what
the [ __ ] you doing like leave the job do
you not I mean so what what and what
helped you get through that I guess
obviously known what your mum's achieved
in her life and these hands helped but
like what helped you get through those
times which is no doubt I'm sure you
felt about quitting and these things
to get through that I think that
fortunately for me I could go home and
mum would be like you'll just have these
days so that helps right because if
you've got a mum but I think sometimes
when you have those moments even if
you're six months in or even now it's
six and a half years into your career
recruitment you know just have those
moments where you just think I want my
doing this for you know you just think
like right is it the big shiny car like
the detached house and or do you want to
just do it because you just like there's
an element of the job that satisfies you
and honestly then I'm not kidding you
and I have it to this day if you can
chat some on the phone and listen to
what they want and find them a job they
want it is so rewarding yeah and I just
have I love candidates that I just kept
placing and placing that's when I did
the month that fifty nearly fifty a
month and they all honestly it was like
recommendation LinkedIn Thank You April
thank you family joke my dreams and half
of the missing the same company six
years on good so it's that feeling it's
like that's what you're doing it for so
so what you're saying there is you
tapped into obviously I liked the idea
of the Rolex but what why am I actually
doing that as recruiters were here to
consult and we don't get taught that
from like the officer yeah for sure I
think I released an episode with a guy
called James Dean and we sort of both
agreed because I had this like we said
like the biggest thing that he learned
was not was not a lot of stop being a
yes-man
yeah I've done if you had that
experience that we're like basically
that transition of being a consultant
you start off like if a client says yeah
not sure about this guy blah blah blah
like yeah yeah okay yeah I understand
then on to the next things you go a
memorizer you get say that so love that
so then what so I think you just tapped
into then but what clique then what are
the things that so you you then you just
said that you really listened to what
people wanted that was it was a key
thing but what what do you think changed
for them to have this huge [ __ ] is
having the confidence to know what I'm
talking about because for the first
seven months you're just like an
industry expert right you think you know
what talking about but you don't but
then just the moment that clicked it was
like I actually know what I'm talking
about I'm enjoying it people are like
listening to me and like people around
you like April you sounded well good on
that call
right now yes so I think when you like
really back yourself not in an
egotistical arrogant way but really
you're really confident that this person
I'm calling now should be speaking to me
because I can actually help yeah and I
know I'm well informed and I know what's
gone on the market but when you actually
truly believe that it's hard it is hard
to get to that point when you're a
couple of months in yes
so I guess just quickly and before we
move on like if I'm sort of a couple of
months in I know what I did but like
what would your advice be to get more
confident and these things would it be
to listen more when you're on the calls
and just find out what lot understand
more about your market by listening and
ask questions you know I mean how did
you get to be more confident I think
that one thing is I can you start in the
cream you need to remember is like
recruitment consultants are busy 360
it's 360 times 10,000 you right I mean
there's so many parts of your job and
when you come in as a newbie you're told
to like sit with the consultants and
since their calls but they're always
going to be busier and they might not
necessarily think of you first so as a
newbie starting out I would honestly say
nag people let me live let me yeah
listen to the calls go to the meetings
find champions find mentors read books
that do everything you can because
unfortunately the world that we live in
people are too busy and women they're
good people or not you know like if I've
got a 20k pitch I need to go out to I
need to go to it and I might have some
training books you know it you know
sometimes you just need to like nag I
don't make but I'll just run off by sin
also buy you dinner he'd actually
probably be really pleasantly surprised
how many people willing to help I'm sure
if you're the right place you'll be
surprised how many people actually
wouldn't help you I was really
interesting really interesting first
time so how much did you build your
first time I'm so cool okay so going
into year two and year free then yeah
did you just continue building like did
you then start building your own knee
knee stop building our own client really
like all my clients they all know what
it was just honestly epic I wish I
actually said this to my boss stack the
other day I was like when
think back of like your happiest time
and I'm absolutely happy now because I
mean you're like 1920 but no worries of
the direct debit that you're paying for
your mobile at big shots walking the
office like billing you know like I knew
what I was talking about my clients just
love honest I loved it yeah that was my
little Empire say 2014-15 when my best
years really yeah cool
so let's so let's just unpack a bit
there as to like so firstly I always get
people to sort of be opening on us about
how they're performing in these things
because I think that's typically what a
lot recruit is lie about right if you go
on a night out right now but I mean so
like what how did you continue continue
to lie increase your buildings that
really it's so hard right if you go on
holiday for ten days and you're months
screwed so you have to like like
pre-plan yeah I definitely stay what you
know annually I always hit target but I
would have months where I did like 3k
really but then the next month would
like make up for it yes I've got this
thing where I honestly believe it to
this day that you should never work hard
work smart so I'm quite reactive right
so I won't necessarily go and build like
five projects a day and message those
people I'll be quite reliant on like the
networks that I have really and that
will be the problem is why I'll have
those three K months because I've
nothing's happening
okay so before we before we move on to
like the tech sales piece just just
interested to just talk a bit more about
see you was seem really happy than when
you're talking about yeah I built this
Empire these things like obviously huge
parts of that is crying's right so like
let's talk a bit about so the most
common thing I get asked about is
business development yeah so like as you
continue to get more confident and
speaking to the clients that you can
help how did you go about building that
Empire what are some of the key things
that you learn and what you've got
better at would you say I would think
just like making the most of candidates
put like questioning where they're
interviewing who they're me
seeing and then you just like start to
build a picture in your head of like
who's hiring and what company and what
role they're having for more candidates
they want and then that those candidates
start to talk about you and they're
building your brand for you hmm
so that by the point you're doing
business development it's not really
hard like card cold-calling it's like
you can be like hey you know like
someone mentioned your name the other
day they said you were hiring or I'm
working with next to this company you
going that way yeah yeah smart
conversations really what do you mean by
that
not not going at it from approach of
like I need to do 60 K this month I need
to get on the phone and like cold call
it's you know every person you meet you
have no idea who they who their network
is or the power that they have or who
they met an hour before they met you or
what their situation is to just chat to
them like humans and then they'll start
to like let things go and then but yeah
I met with terrier you know X Y Zed he's
hiring for a beedi Eamon but I really I
mean you just start to build honesty
start building a little Empire and you
start to know who's hiring where they're
hiring what level they're hiring how
much they're paying if they using
agencies and then by the time you go and
have that conversation that cold call
that first prospecting email you're sure
of what's going on and then actually
yeah I really like the way that you put
that so if I'm if I'm a recruit right
now and I'm not having smart BD calls
how do I start doing that because that
makes complete sense but like a recruit
is world is quite chaos you know I mean
so like the way that you broke that down
now really lights that but how can I
start doing more of that so it's ask
better questions from the candidates
make the most of that I think you've
mentioned a bit there about actually
approach these conversations like just
genuine conversation like oh my god I
need to get this out this conversation
or if I don't get more out of these BD
calls and I'm not going to hit my 60 K
target etcetera so how like just just
some just some practical tips and to get
more in that position to ask have more
small conversations then within my tech
you've got like social you've got email
you've got that multi-channel model at
all these different areas then you want
to be looking at like the best companies
to work for like x talk 100 and then
that's the kind of brands that you want
to sell anywheres
right and then look at the hiring
managers and just like be follow what
they're doing on LinkedIn and be like
hey notice you did this the other day I
noticed you held this event and just
message them doesn't the the first
message or interaction you have with a
prospect doesn't need to be to sell your
services it can just hey you know let's
do a podcast together you're totally
right I think and I think we're also
great to sell our me and I think we'll
get onto this because it's something
obviously that I'm building a business
around our personal branding these
things and I think that is where that is
where recruiters are missing the trick
like the best recruiters don't go
straight in there and essentially what
you're talking about there is they're
thinking about what can I go of this
relationship like from day one you know
I mean and obviously you have to be to
the point sometimes otherwise you're not
gonna get anything out the relationship
but it doesn't mean you always have to
start with like what you want out of it
and straight there to get I mean cool so
you then went into tech sales what did
you get what you require shop and said
what just give me a bit of insight into
that so light and what what type of tech
solutions we turning it was you can call
it tech it's like ad tech its campaign
led it's a bit it's not like software
sales automated buying selling that
media online so it's like go onto the
daily mail right and you've been doing
some shopping a JD go on the daily man
you've got a few trainers and discount
bloody how nice is it when you go
shopping and they're showing you what
you want yeah okay so and I said
and then give me a bit of a flavor as to
light so that was straight b2b yes okay
oh really that's your crime back yeah
yeah so I sell in touch 20 mirror right
so if you're all total jobs okay so if
you were looking for jobs so your
typical crime would be a lot of people
are told Rob really so how did one cream
in businesses like take that budgets and
they'll have different teams and think
about how can we you know yeah well
answer these people know just interested
so I guess so just went from that I
guess what so what was you likewise you
excited by that was it just like honesty
is epic and you learn so much based very
like head down doing demos may be quiet
rooms and it's maybe not the same
culture from like bantering around the
office fun sociable I don't really know
I don't speak on behalf of everyone else
I really went to work for a big brand as
well II would like a thousand people so
going from like a fifty-mile tech on
recruitment company to a thousand
company because I always seen it's good
to have a mixture of both mm-hmm because
if you've got exposure to the CEO in one
company right and then one day you've
got a goes like jump through hoops to
get anything done it's good to have that
balance okay
so before we get into when you joined
why's it mm-hmm
just just on that point because I have
my own experience that I went from a big
insurance company to then a small
independent insurance broker had direct
access to the owner and and went to an
agency of eight people were sat next to
the owner in the business so you mention
dancing it's good to experience both
definitely agree what what would you say
and also now working at wise you can
obviously include that as well what's
been sort of your thoughts on the pros
and cons of working for a bigger company
to a business where you have direct
access to the owner and your experiences
there what would you say jumping through
thing like you don't really have
exposure I've some my prayer
is always a smaller company yeah but I
think just having exposure to like the
view of the business and where it's
going so it's like at v-- you know is
really hard to know and like any day
like what was going on if it was good or
bad really
and then I guess also with that is like
when we saying earlier about like
happens like why you're doing it it's a
bit harder to understand that you know I
mean it just feels a bit more like way
yes my job a lot I sell this but there's
a bit less wide behind in there ok
anything else to add to that there could
be a few more takeaways or not well I
what's been the best there what's been
one of the big benefits for you then for
working for a smaller business or small
grain business you come in and you have
your job title right let's say like
recruitment consultant you have your
target and you have your market but like
if the CEOs coming in one day in a small
company you know that they're having a
day where it's like guys where the
numbers what's going on you really see
that like they need it not in a yeah oh
my god we're struggling kind of way that
you understand why they're doing it like
you get exposure to their body language
when I'm thinking it why they set it up
so like all of a sudden you get that
like spark that comes back in you like
yes I'm actually doing this yeah that's
pretty good point so it's like getting
exposure to that I just died honestly I
don't think it can be bought it's
brilliant you can't put a price on that
so what would your advice be to someone
that again because the thing there's a
lot of people they'll get their first
job in recruiting them I stand at a year
two years three years then again
absolutely came by rhetoric because
they've got a year to experience right
and they're thinking right look there's
loads of jobs out there and I'll see the
thing is recruitment is a very high
demand skillset
right so there'll be a lot of people
listening that may be in a big company
smaller company and growing business
like what do you think you mentioned two
things there but if I'm a real crude
right now a bit of a crossroads I'm not
right should I join a smaller business
should have join a big big business like
Hayes or s3 or whatever what would you
be sending those people and I'm
definitely grew that on cool so we now
get onto wiser you got made redundant
sadly share that point we were like okay
like maybe I should get back into
recruitment yeah did you want to get
back I mean
there was a company that went for for a
short period of time that's not you know
not on the LinkedIn profile not on the
LinkedIn profile bad experience quite
honest I am I took like three months off
for joining Weiser I had massively
suffered from depression
Wow sorry I was gonna say I went to Bali
oh and traveling I think I did one day
definitely for me just to let you know
that last thing for me to talk about an
open honest way so we'll definitely talk
about that but I guess like so how did
you get to the point as quickly as to
how you got to Weiser though so I saw I
was selling to Weiser at V and I came
across a fantastic guy who's still
raised a guy called will Cooper he's in
the sales team but I was trying to sell
to him and little did I know he was
trying to sell to me as well any message
me in January like I'm actually looking
I came in met Jack catheral net will and
I honestly just loved it and my hey I've
been messaging you consistently for like
four years and you just and that's how
I'm here yeah and so you've been here
for 18 months yeah indeed okay as you
brought up let's talk about it yes so
you had a couple of months off yep what
was going on I just had a bit of like
moment was like what on earth is going
on because when you go from how do you
do this one so easy because I didn't go
to Union I thought which straight into
work 18 I was like in this fast-paced
like recruitment job for like three and
a half years there's like top biller for
two years in a row
going to Vegas loving life or everything
which is going really well and then when
you go from like quite quick turnaround
in McCrimmon that you can turn your
months like around quite quickly
software sales is another beast you know
you need to be really smart and you need
to have like real training to be
successful software selves and then I
joined this company and it was just an
absolute [ __ ] she went from like he went
from that top dog to like yeah it was
nothin yeah basically
summers eager just start to question
myself really really doing that and I
just thought I just don't know what I'm
gonna do did you over those three months
and there was a mixture of light so you
went from that whole journey which looks
it must have been tough yeah so then was
looking at self in the mirror and like
purpose about yeah absolutely it was so
frustrating but luckily you know these
things happen so so what like what sort
of things did you learn for that period
then cuz like obvious you can now
clearly I know something you're
passionate about I've seen the stuff you
put on LinkedIn and stuffs Alliance yeah
what have you learned learnt through
that process of obvious I'm sure plenty
of days were like oh my god what am i
doing my life yes - down on yourself for
this alliance what looking back which is
always a great thing what sort of things
did you take from that whole experience
then I think I just let things get me
way too easily really you know that if
you meet some of those successful people
in the world like salespeople are just
in general one of the things they do
really well is just consistently you
don't show their emotion or don't get
attached to things showing emotion I
meant that in the sales process yeah a
bit too mostly attached yeah way too
attached deal that's not happening
affect me so much that I would not -
really good point I've done it it's my
fault what have I done wrong where's
just don't get attached to it just carry
on the next one then the next on the
next one
so I look back now and I would never be
that person ever again
like I had a good guy not accepting off
the other day and I honestly laughed at
it I was like on to the next one that's
two years ago so what was that the
biggest thing then so like going through
that period you like April like a con I
can't get so attached I can't let
basically your circumstances dictate how
you feel and these things right yeah I
think just to add to what you said there
because that was one of my biggest
challenges and to be totally honest with
you a lot of the and a lot the
consultants I work with were female and
I think obviously my opinion but you
guys are a lot easier to get emotionally
attached to that yeah exactly which is
cool like obviously there's pros and
cons for that obviously but I think what
I had to get better right is totally
that is that it's one I think there's a
mixture of you can't get really
emotionally attached and
let that deal falling out dictate how
you approach the rest of the afternoon
on how you feel but you have to be
willing to look in the mirror and take
accountability and say okay what I've
done better yeah exactly so it's less
like April what the hell have you done
like this is your fault like what have
you done wrong bla bla bla and more so
okay what could have done better in that
situation from it and move on with it
versus going I'm an idiot it was my
phone getting in a strop and then
walking off mm-hmm there's always more
you could have done always and that's
like the frustrating thing there is
always more you could have done when is
it a time you've gone actually did
everything right there and it just
happens that's interesting thank you for
sharing that's a lie I guess how
obviously through that whole experience
it helps you cut over the sort of minds
that you have now but how did you start
implement in that do you know I mean
because it can't just just gone like
that so like obviously you just said
there that obviously that's that's how
you used to be be really emotionally
attached like something and dropped out
you'd let yourself in the room yeah now
you're wiser and obviously you haven't
got that approach that three months
helped you I guess molded so then you
don't have practices that way but how
did you start when things didn't go bad
what did you start doing differently did
you go I mean yeah I mean them yet I
still have those days have you I don't
know do you have any new habits that you
know it's like if you look at other
areas in the job that you love I can
obviously like this event side that I've
started doing I know it sounds really
silly but I actually fallen over the
whole part of myself that I didn't even
know existed like helping people
so like when you've got another part to
your job that you love you those little
things don't really make such a big
impact to you okay
does that make sense things though so
it's like what let's say when I started
wise and my role was full 360
recruitment come in build a desk yeah
get clients close candidates get people
jobs right so when I connect didn't
accept that's so crucial to my success
so crucial it was a number like numbers
were you hitting number you're newbie
you're coming in your building your desk
I'd be like oh my god this is the CEOs
can be looking at me but no one is but
they're not now where you start to like
build your brand and you start to adapt
the industry like running in community
doing the event side the little bit
as much of an impact and that's why I
think it's so important as a recruiters
no matter how far you go in your career
it's really important you try to do
other parts of the job as well mm-hmm
even though recruitment itself is like
10 you have to do it I think I really
like that I think obviously let
recruitment super repetitive I think
yeah if you can even though it's in is
actually beneficial to that what you're
doing and there and it enables it and it
helps it but yeah it gives you someone
else to think about
yeah that's friend is there anything
else in like if I'm a recruit right now
I'm going hateful yeah really good point
but I can't do anything like that like I
wouldn't be supported to do that like
there's anything else that has has
helped you and react better to those
types of things go to Jack can you give
me 20 grand to go run an event I didn't
have any budget I didn't do it you know
like it was my personal goal to go right
when I get more females into sales teams
its do an event about it that means that
my job is now more diverse so like you
don't need how did you sell it to one of
them I think for me it was like a
personal objective and they're really
big or like you see ya know the reason
why I wanted to dig a bit deeper there
is because like totally get you a point
I think it's a really really good point
but I was just kidding if there's
anything else that has sort of ended up
in the April life that it's an able to
deal with his life if you're crying
about Canada didn't accept it we'll get
over it move on there's like thousands
and thousands of salespeople under and
we'll find that person I will get cool
now I really like that it's perspective
it's mindset it's something you've got a
copy of it right I think oh I just
thought you might have ended up talking
about maybe meditation and like that
just because that that's helped me a lot
and the people on the panel for that
we've got a mindfulness coach and that
kind of thing
come in and I teach sales directors how
they can implement changes into cell
phones so I'm quite intrigued by it
because I've never really really like
pursued it for me like yeah I had
therapy helped it helped me but for me
it's like keeping busy doesn't want to
sit down and like okay cool so 18 months
at wiser how's it been really I love it
like the first day I joined really yeah
why is that
they've just chat like it's actually a
one-liner but they've Jen you changed
where people think about work they can
probably see by the culture in the
environment here yeah a speciality it's
very unique it's like that's like no
[ __ ] people like it generally is
unique laughs no joke because everyone
says they're unique but you can feel
that as soon as you walk in how much
time and effort and what he does for
people is just incredible like he's
trained me and my mindset now is solely
down to the way that he's made me think
he's given me you know like I'm unique
in the way that I do things I can be
loud I can be quiet
I can't waver he's completely adapted
he's given me the just the platform to
build my brand now and it's honestly
she's brilliant okay cool
so let's unpack that a bit just one
thing the horn is touching because you
said that you said that earlier about
Billy back-to-back yeah skip that part
and how have you done building one since
you've been here
again like percentage-wise on numbers
numbers it was actually the last year
syrtis that did like 207 okay cool so
one thing that I always like to talk to
people about because a lot of people and
ask me like he should mom sort of loved
for people to talk about and so
basically a lot of people say to me hey
Jim I'd love you to sort of uncover how
someone went from like 100 to 200 300 or
whatever right because a lot of people
may feel like they've hit that glass in
if they call it a billion
50 K or whatever right yeah so I guess
and from your perspective like what are
some of the over this period I know it
seemed like it's all been your getting
better being consistent and you're
always trying to get your billions to go
one direction but like what and what are
some of the sort of key things that have
changed over that you've changed over
the last couple years of sort of helped
you think that helps you get your
billions to the next level or you've had
an increase in how you're done
performance wise and things like that is
there anything worth talking about there
that you saw changed for straight and
constant getting at the 150 to 180 mark
oh yeah it is really really hard to
build more than two hundred and fifty
grand a year as an individual consultant
with no no like I've never build more
than 250 260 like as an individual
contributor okay so and that for people
that question themselves not why can't
it be really hard you have to be working
14-hour days you have to be like
building projects and night working
Sunday afternoons and then that that
works for some people
hmm so for me like you know honestly
like I've never been a manager I've
never like I've never had a resource to
it why's there like everything because
I'm not very good will be done sitting
down to me so don't feel doubtful that
that's not success it's what defines
your success is like what you've
actually achieved in that year right
doing like one I think 192 last year but
within that they say to build a brand
you stop post on LinkedIn you know doing
events and things like that and then
that defines success to me I really like
that you know lot of directors would be
I want me not what view numbers number
no I think I think that's a really good
point because um I think no I think
that's really a good point because I
guess what you also said there is okay
so if it is just you and your bill and
you build turned okay for the last two
years like walk like could there be an
extra resource like is that an option
have you thought about getting someone
in underneath you that can work that's a
really good point and in also as you
just said like your your your success
isn't just defined by it
obviously the N Billings amount I really
like that have you been around big big
build as I like what in terms of that
before she was at Dartmouth that she
built quite a lot of money but then you
also need to look at like the the setup
and the deal values and the contracts
and things like that everything is
relevant in its industry yeah you know
like doing half a million a year that
might be executive search you've got 10
people working on one account and then
they were like feeding into least hmm
like if you look at the numbers what of
that was your numbers that you build on
your own 24k wasn't this a war and
always interested to ask and then we'll
get behind to the brand and stuff
because we'd love to get your
perspective in your experience what does
a typical April Turner structure look
like so when you're doing well yeah what
tell me about your day how is that
structure because people always
interested in that like yeah
talk to me a bit about your stretch
because I'm sure that's hard to evolve
and get better I think I can say on this
my structure has definitely gotten a bit
more less structured as times gone on
okay but the people that are starting
recruitment we use honestly getting a
right to do lift him 8:00 to 8:30 and it
would be segmented by what how many
series you want to send who you want to
send them to registrations that day
median so all right then like 8:30 to
9:30 you'd be like thinking about what
client you want to work on that day yeah
11:30 you just be doing it resourcing
going through job boards calling booking
Karen the me book Anna inlet your pre
life satisfy like Gilman yeah and then
after that BD so that you can go at it
like that mmm-hmm but realistically like
how how many days of the year can you go
in you must have some I use that work
hard at work smart not hard yeah you
know not just like reaching out to
people learning from them we've got the
elite the sales community that we've got
now which is pretty much a job in itself
at making sure the contents there so
it's quite reactive my job okay I mean
you know people that listen to some
years experience I'm a crewman that
won't be right for them
building their own empire mm-hmm how I
structure my day is very much based on
like what's gonna be an opportunity for
me to why don't you want to make money
yeah
but then also an opportunity for me to
build my own brand so you need to spot
an opportunity and jump on it not always
be the idea that's working 20-hour days
but not ya know making anything from it
that's fine it's fine that's cool
so you've mentioned a few times building
my brand what does that mean to your
brand there's no brain there now what is
that what does that mean to use a
recruit because obviously when you start
the news 18 I'm sure you didn't have
your mom talk about personal brand
exactly so talk to me like what like
what does that mean to you as a
recruiter like what does building my
brand mean to you April you name come up
for this event the other day yeah how
where like where does that happen
mm-hmm it's really hard to quantify what
your personal brand means always worth
it's just like sharing things on
LinkedIn here and there or just being me
no it doesn't necessarily mean pushing
things out in social media it's more
just like my brand is me I'm loud I go
with the flow I have an opinion I'm
pretty black-and-white you know this is
my views and things happy to always
listen to others but like that's my
Brandon have you always been that way
that always I'd say more so now after
what happened a few years ago okay no no
no okay cool so then so how does that
transfer in the online world I like the
way that you put that because I think
that's where a lot of recruiters are
missing the part that's what anything is
there the end of the day the biggest
asset that you have and any recruit has
it's listening to this is themselves and
what you're talking about there what
makes April April right so I guess like
what just tell me a bit about that
journey because there'll be people
listening that have heard me speak about
it and they know it's important but
they're so scared to put April out there
and these things like talk to me a bit
about the journey of like building your
brand you know I mean what talk to me a
bit about that we kind of collectively
as a company were like that let's kind
of test the water with pushing content
out on LinkedIn okay as consultants
mm-hmm you know and then we
kind of said that what write something
online that you you know really pisses
you off okay but not in a bad way but
like talked about it from an educational
point of view okay
so put something on Nicktoons that you
know might educate your network mm-hmm
so I was like right you know what annoys
me is that every client I work this says
they want a 2-1 grad from a Russell
Butte University and that means that
they're gonna be more successful than
someone that does it and exciting go to
uni so I put this post out LinkedIn and
it got like crazy responses like 500
likes or something that's before that
all I was doing was jobs like going how
much money did you make from pricing
about jobs zero don't do that guys he
doesn't work so yes I put this post out
and then from there I kind of found my
voice to be honest with you
really yes you got a really big win like
early on what happened at the back about
young people crazy some people messaging
me and I tried to like push more and
more content out there and and then you
know the timing on and then it was more
like meeting with so when I funny story
if NASA was listening she's might she's
a legend asthma is a client of mine and
we actually went for drinks and she was
a bit mentor and she was a twitch don't
you do enough of and I said I don't
travel enough sweetie booked flights to
Iceland we went two weeks later but then
I started to share those stories of like
NASA my client in Iceland on LinkedIn
and you know you just start to like
build a picture of who you are and then
it comes natural you know and then the
events off the back of that side
happening so when you say it comes
natural you mean be an April on line but
that came from you I'm sure being a bit
uncomfortable to start with or like I
like I kept writing that post like 15
times you worried about who are asking
for those two on grants and Russell
groups it's a bit why I did on a rough
you know you're not gonna get anywhere
by being soft are you yeah that's really
true okay and then your opinion then so
how long have you been on that journey
for would you say I started that
probably like summer last year it's
about year okay yeah how first question
I get is okay how much money is gonna
make me really hard to quantify honest
you spent
time on it so but how would you say a
year our year later how is it benefiting
to you as a recruiter how is it benefit
you as a person so if you're looking at
it from a beedi perspective right so
that's our messaging you know a prospect
a if they're like looking at my LinkedIn
and they say I'm pushing out content
they probably get build a picture of Who
I am yes
so they find it much easier to respond
to me because they probably know you
know I'm legit I'm obviously not going
at it in a normal like recruiter said
yeah recommendations yeah so just get a
feel for what we're all about and it
just means that the whole process is
much easier you know if you've got this
bog standard black and white LinkedIn
profile with like
for the red tie white shirt maybe navy
suit kind of recruiter approach and
they're Roli so it's helped you sue and
then what is that compared to them
people talk about when you speak them on
the phone that's the big thing
yeah recommendations referrals yeah I
really like the way that you put that
because I think generally like that that
is the seat that is the secret to it all
which isn't that much of a secret if you
go I'm in because I think at the end of
the day that's totally right if you're
if you're sliding into my DMS right and
on the other name a tech salesperson
you're probably the fifth person sliding
by the ends that day and who'd wanna
engage me before I go on April Turner's
profile I said no a bit more about April
or I've gone to some one year about the
person you're describing that hasn't
shared anything that's relevant to me
yeah will shed anything besides like the
jobs of those profiles every recruiter
would love to chat to and I often ask
the question is that why did you apply
some message he was like it was just
human and it was normal and you could
see that there was a bit more to a story
than sending out a 200 man project on
LinkedIn not saying that that's what's
the balance right so for me it's like
yeah not obviously I love the way that
you put that because obviously one is
happen quite naturally you've become
more comfortable being you and like that
literally is it like that's the like you
don't need to overcomplicate like to
start yeah yeah it's hard to get into it
but generally
it's it's time obviously isn't it but I
think isn't gonna be uncomfortable
Armand when I did my first video lie I
was really stiff like I was horrible
like openly share it because it's grim
yeah like it's fine
but I did about did it about 20 times 20
times to do it I've got some weird
haircut going on like it's just like but
you have to start somewhere and as you
said I totally agree like you gradually
just get more confident sharing who you
are and I think the ultimate goal here
this whole buzzword personal branding
the ultimate goal here which hopefully
this will relate to you is if April
Turner misses me if I'm a crown or a
candidate and then that process goes
from April calling me or you engage with
me and then we meet or we then speak on
the phone or whatever the goal here is
why wait prove exactly how for you was
right I'm sure you've heard that right
that's the gut that's the whole goal
with this and that is if you're a
recruiter that's your that's your
biggest asset that's why I'm gonna work
with April / Tom down the road who like
doesn't you know I mean I don't know
Tommy it means so everyone wants this
point of difference but ultimately that
it's you and I think cool so I guess
last beyond that I know you sort of
touched on it but it'd be good just to
get your opinions - like right now I'm
in recruitment I'm hearing this I'm like
April I'm so scared
what's your go-to advice - like start
because I have my own advice with that
but like what would you say to someone
it's get scared to start like doing
being me online and these things about
what then you don't start showing
context it might be not what people want
to hear about but you know it's actually
quite a hard question to answer
you just gotta go with what you're
thinking as long as it's not offensive
okay I would honestly say that make what
is there to lose honestly yes and I
always think when I have but when I've
got a family and they're like oh mom
like what would your like what was a day
for you that you're just like oh it all
worked out it's like you just got to
make sure that you tell your kids that
you weren't like you can work hard for
it and you just went with it yeah don't
be scared to type in a bloody status on
LinkedIn and show what's the worst thing
that's gonna happen Bob saying and I'm
offended by your pose but like just get
rid of it there
go with it no one might change the world
overnight by sitting behind the screen
did they salute as we wrap up then so I
guess a few things actually so for you
then you so you are now in a slightly
different role so you started as just
out-and-out recruiter yes so just
quickly actually female in tech and tech
cells these things how'd that come about
like why are you passionate about that
because that's what event to recruitment
as well did you know what it is for me
it's just the impact that it has the
performance of a team I think people
don't think about enough lab right so
you know if you're and when I saw all
topic is obviously very sensitive is
only certain things you can say about it
but you know I do believe male or female
like you could still do right so I'm not
saying that like men think they're doing
a better job than women none of that
it's just you know as a woman naturally
you mentioned it earlier we get more
attached to like things not going well
we get emotional so if I might sitting
with like a very heavy heavily male
dominated sales team who don't
understand and I'm like I just want to
chat to like a female boss about that or
some of my team who's like it helps
right so if I'm pissed off in my job I
don't feel like anyone's appreciating
what I'm saying that means I'm not gonna
perform which then ultimately affects
the company's performance mmm-hmm so
don't understand why people not thinking
about it mmm-hmm does that make sense
that's the angle that I'm coming at it
from us that it makes sense to have
equally balanced so do you proactively
try and get more females in your
industry then no I wouldn't say that
because in that's like the whole like
you know unconscious bias thing of like
thinking you're trying to sell me I mean
there's nothing wrong if you have an
intention to try and get but you know
we're lucky here wise we've got like
fifty six percent female but obviously
we've got creative team and recruitment
team but even the recruitment flow is
pretty balanced I think if you're if
you're seen to trying to be doing it it
does it's not appealing if you've ever
tried like you know if I really want to
females like he's a [ __ ] I think I
think I'll tell you go.you min but and
then nothing just comes down because
that's my whole bit I'll agree a bit
also that would be a lot the mental
health Inger I think is such an easy
word to use now do you know I mean I
think that oh you mean so but I think
the end the day it comes back to just
talking about the second and go whereas
if you are if your fate was talking
about it and then I sit down in the room
of April and like you're talking about
the same thing laughing that's fair
enough like it's you were actually being
real about it because I'm sure there's a
lot of companies that you work with that
say yeah like diversity is really
important to us and then they ask you
and then like you get a few females with
a delight now you know I mean we all
know what's going on you know I mean so
it's like cool so I guess as we finish
then so you are now going into a
slightly different role yes
well yeah creep man so it's like some
see the unique thing about wise there is
obviously it's a half employed brand
they okay so I guess what's your view on
employer brand and these things then
like what are you talking to businesses
about that it's crazy and a recruiter in
fact I had done a half employer brand I
didn't see like did you typically talk
about that if you didn't work for wiser
yes little things right so you know I'm
software sales person I've got an
amazing profile but I've been given ten
job specs five of them have got black
font on white paper five of them are
like PDS brochures interviews of the
sales directors what made them
successful where would you go just off
of basis of your jobs know where to go
now if you look at the candidate
experience in the journey that they're
going through and why they're saying no
to job specs or why they're saying no to
like applying for a job it's all the way
that your brand's being perceived online
and I promise you now that employer
branding is gonna be more important than
consumer branding one day how come how
come we're cruising pile that you can
just buy your clients right like I came
here with no idea what improv branding
was and even now I've been a recruiter
up until three months ago
like I'm I'm no expert but it's the
basics sure it's like guys your LinkedIn
photos your sales directors holding a
beer do you know what I mean like that
needs to change sound professional you
know the contents not consistent across
LinkedIn profiles people are jumping
around the glass or reviews a bad just
like generally like if I was looking for
a job would I go to you probably not and
it's okay to be honest mmm-hmm obviously
don't offend them
you know it's interesting under string
Kennard everything over I totally agree
but it's like I'm just trying to fit in
like how the hell do I unpack that do
not mean I totally get it's basically
like no to influence that because
obviously not it's an inner accrues
interest
yeah for sure again I think it's coming
back to being consultative right so our
fingers totally right and I think she's
finally interested in like yeah okay
um what what son what are some of the
common things that your sin and the
common pitfalls that people make as you
mentioned some of the basics there but
what are the common things that you see
there people just going way wrong with
their employer brand that you've just
seen it's hard to quantify you can't
really see like the talent you're losing
out on but you know like imagine you
know like looking at it's hard to say
you know Salesforce there might have
been the top billing software sales
person or a call that's gone on to sell
services website and they've left cuz it
looks rubbish you can't see that because
how much talent you know that you're
losing out on you don't know
what kid all right well look I always
like to ask people what's what's what's
April excited by at the moment what's
gone on in your world and one event
coming up mental health in tech sales in
sales not just X out obviously which is
solely sales professionals so cool it'll
be heavily like and what's the sort of
agenda behind that like what what sort
of message you trying to get to these
people or what sort of values you see I
want to learn from it as well yeah of
course
that we can like execute this change
ourselves teams without it being based
around what you think you should be
doing you know like for example sending
out phones ring and sorry guys I closed
the deal it's all about how can we help
sales team perform better because having
up like having months where it's like
not going well I'm working 12-hour days
like it has an impact on you and I think
it's just how can we
salespeople boom open-minded and educate
you know like your team on what to look
out for is the same equipment isn't that
suicide for that anything else that's
amazing more alert I think I've really
enjoyed this open - I think and what I
always ask people before we finish is
one question you can answer it with a
phrase just a sentence or word whatever
comes to mind so if if you could
communicate every single recruit out
there they'd listen they take on an
advice it implements it to Moorea what
would you be telling them just keep
going good advice I keep going cool
it's been a pleasure thank you so very
much